we would want to kill Andy hey youtubers
is Charlie this week on arrow Oliver
took full advantage of the phrase what
happens in Russia stays in Russia we got
our first look at Amanda Waller Deadshot
came back giving us a teaser of secret
six things to come later this season and
we learned that hive is going to be one
of the big bads of the season so let's
talk about our favorite moments as well
as the big DC Universe references and
then I'll do my review
so first Amanda Waller is now part of
arrow she leads Argus which is basically
like DC universes version of shield so
instead of helping the Avengers like
shield does they help the Justice League
Amanda Waller has always been a bit of a
frenemy to superheroes in past
incarnations on television and in the
comics so if she ends up helping team
arrow this season it'll only be under
the most dire of circumstances we will
be seeing the Suicide Squad as I teased
earlier we will see bronze Tiger
comeback Michael Jai White he'll come
back on the show it's likely that now
that Deadshot is basically free now in
the wild Amanda Waller will capture him
and compel him into service so covering
the rest of the Russia bases Oliver in
Isabel totally hook up Isabel rochev if
you remember was part of Oliver's
father's list he was in that book of
names the title of the episode was keep
your enemies closer so obviously that
was really a reference to Deadshot and
Diggle but that could also be a
reference to Oliver in Isabel and in my
last video I post the theory that she
could be Talia al Ghul or a super
villain on the show just posing as a
normal person but more to that hookup I
totally got a Dark Knight Rises vibe so
I am thinking that she is an evil person
on the show I'll talk more about that
later when I talk about hive though
felicity was totally not down with all
of her shenanigans I felt really bad for
her on the show because she's one of my
favorite characters but during Comic Con
Stephen Amell and Emily BETT Rickards
said that Oliver and Felicity will not
have sex on the show like they're not
you know like have a big hookup like
Isabel and Oliver did they will get so
close to the season though that they
seemed like a married couple think about
it this way does that make oliver
hooking up with all these women and he
will Stephen Amell said that Oliver is
going to hook up with a lot of women
this season does that mean that he is
cheating on her technically I think it
does right below in the comments yes or
no so the other big storyline is dr. Ivo
back on the Amazo boat they're basically
looking for those skeletons that we saw
in the cave earlier in the season it
turns out that they're basically looked
at Japanese versions of Captain
erricka super-soldiers and i bows
basically trying to replicate that serum
we don't get a lot more info but we do
see Slade with like half his face burnt
so he is basically almost Deathstroke at
this point because remember Deathstroke
only has one eye but there was one big
DC Universe reference that kind of tied
everything together it was really cool
so think about it this way hive was
mentioned during the episode hive is
like an evil version of Argus or like an
evil version of shield however you want
to think about it it's basically a bunch
of super villains that team up to try
and take down superheroes but basically
I'm thinking they have something to do
with the brother Bloods storyline so
that means that they also probably have
something to do with a lot of the other
villains on the show so here's where it
all ties together so Argus and The
Suicide Squad will eventually probably
butt heads with hive once we learn more
about them but the really interesting
thing though is is that Slade Wilson's
wife Deathstroke remember half his face
burnt on the island that Slade his
ex-wife formed hive and who else is a
member of hive Talia al Ghul remember my
theory about how Isabel rochev might be
Talia al Ghul in disguise it would
totally make sense that hive would try
to gain a foothold in Queen industries
to help them take over Starling city and
there were several episodes in we're
starting to get enough dots that we can
start connecting the larger storyline
let me know what your theory is on hive
is the bell roach f and how it all fits
together but next week count vertigo is
coming back he's into the character from
the DC Universe be sure to subscribe to
get my video but what did I think of the
episode this was actually one of my
favorite episodes all season I give it a
solid b-plus
I love the Russia field trip it was a
nice change of pace visually I liked all
the new sets one of the things I really
love about arrow is that it totally does
not shy away from making references to
big things big characters superheroes in
the DC Universe they're doing the flash
this season they did Black Canary
they're just bringing it all on and it's
only in season two as opposed to shows
like agents of shield which are being a
little bit stingy with the references
obviously that's getting a little bit
better too but let me know what your
favorite moment slash hookups were don't
worry what happens on emergency awesome
stays on emergency awesome so I'll be
posting the schedule for the rest of the
videos I'll be posting this week in the
comments below but tomorrow morning I
will be posting my American Horror Story
coven video and then the afternoon I'll
be posting my next Doctor Who 50th
anniversary video so be sure to check
the description for the schedule right
now click here to learn what's going on
on arrow this season and
here to learn what's going on on agents
of shield this season thank you so much
for watching I'll see you guys tomorrow
high fives
you